have you ever wondered about the
relationship between two measures for
example what happens to patient
satisfaction when people have longer
wait times a scatterplot is a graphical
tool used to examine the association
between two measures it's a powerful
tool for helping us understand
relationships and associations between
two variables scatter plots can be
helpful for doing PDSA testing to
understand variables that might affect
the project measures scatter pots help
us to see unusual patterns data affected
by special causes and interesting
clustering of data points it also can
show how changes in process measures are
affecting outcomes here's an example of
a scatter diagram showing a negative
relationship so let's imagine again that
we've got waiting time in we'll put time
down here in minutes and we're doing 10
20 30 40 50 make a straight arrow so
this is the x-axis and then on the
y-axis we're gonna put satisfaction so
we're doing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 9 all
right so this is our scatter plot
all right so imagine as we're looking at
this and we start collecting data from
our patients that we start to see a
series of dots and as basically as time
increases we see patient satisfaction
decrease it creates kind of a picture
like this and when we see data look this
way right so as the time is increasing
the score the patient satisfaction score
is dropping we call this a negative
relationship
so if satisfaction scores increased as
time increased we would have a positive
correlation if the dots are randomly
displayed like a shotgun blast we'd say
there's no correlation one important
thing to note is relationship or
correlation is not the same as causation
there are statistical tools and methods
to determine whether relationship is due
to chance alone or a statistically
important most commercial spreadsheet
programs have an option to create a
scatterplot can you think of measures
related to a process you're trying to
improve that may benefit from doing a
scatterplot
you